- I'm going to read you a bedtime story.
It's called Goodnight Internet.
(harp music)
- In a small pink bedroom
there was an iPhone.
- And a text saying LOL.
And a phone case with Harry Styles
bought at the mall.
- And there were Pinterest boards
with lyrics from Lorde and fun makeup tips
for cherry red lips.
- Pictures of the fam,
triple filtered on Instagram.
- Lulu Lemon pants and a cup of tea.
- And a bowl of pasta,
that's also gluten free.
- A French Bulldog with
his own Tumblr blog.
- A Frozen DVD and a super hot selfie.
- A set of gel nails and a sweater
from an Urban Outfitter sale.
- Goodnight crop top, good night Shop Bop.
- Goodnight Starbucks, Vanilla Cake Pop.
- Goodnight Netflix.
Goodnight selfie sticks.
- Goodnight creepy Tinder match.
Goodnight Benedict Cumberbatch.
(whip sound)
- Goodnight Taylor Swift.
Goodnight Beyonce gif.
- Goodnight Ariana Grande,
goodnight pumpkin spice latte.
- Goodnight Snapchat.
Goodnight Grumpy Cat.
- Goodnight Candy Crush and
goodnight Sephora makeup brush.
- Goodnight to my bae and
goodnight Lana Del Rey.
- Goodnight Olivia Pope.
Goodnight Leslie Knope.
- Goodnight followers, goodnight friends.
- Goodnight all my
favorite internet trends.
- Goodnight laptop powered down with care.
Goodnight internet users everywhere.
(harp music)
- What are you doing with my harp?